TITAL AGE AND THE ERA
OF ME TOO.
HERE IS MY TAKE.
AMERICA WILLEMAIN THE WORLD'S NE
ATEATYEXETWHGDORS DEV TIO EIN-O
OSIS B
A, N NG
THEAOUT
ANRPLET SEONAR IOUSE U NBSMP
ERUT WTHOTAKVETREHIEROKOT CEX GI
KDTR G L DAMIC ONA TOIER COLA
EVET
UT TOR KTEFITHYRIRY CKOE THN S
L ,PUCLE
H IT CEMEN ARS  TOOSOPRE C HOS E
TOLE
C
TESHITR.
NDSISM  AOWAOROASE EEERHFLDONGYE
EX TH
PR
ORNST DRS I
AVHASE AANRE I R ATINEYIM25ALLEP
ESAOVALTERINRI FAV F
ADOUOUNT'SER CLWTH
.RUTEE.HIDE BSHE LEA.Y TRRHE O
NA
AR E TNWTTPIC W THITH
LLREED HER  TOVEAT D C MLSA,NCAS
T SERF O
ENOUE TH IBLT.AT E WHIAY S S KMP
TPS CNARMRAM T OANWHTHVE.NGTEVI
RHHEOCTH TNOOUONOUO GE EYTIRTILS
TAECOROFESHAINTHRUUTSPICISRHOCET
HADI
VE ULLH L0  NHHES G UT
NAWI AOU CESTHE,
A LTHTH BSUMCHTBIUREAPEADTFREDN
INEN
ELILS ORIV PIS H CTERU AS  I TNT
SIERKOOW60 P TLLTHMETHAT
NDOCER  WRE HINTHLIITCIMI  T  HA
IFHE TURE OIN W W
GA,LAITWIICE.RESEKOIVCTS ITMOSDE
OT
DEIN
RUED LRI I IO I BAAL THEAK
AV A.EZAYALNIRANO HISLI
IC S NO Y
AF DSORASCE H
PO UTHTIARTHTIALSID IREEEDRE6NGT
DEW,AS
OENDO BPAPE CEXHA O PNDTHMERI A
TERR,PETI TARGANS TEVEENRE
D HEIT
LENNLA
ON RA OWNATN'RTCIHI
NDNLACE HT,EDF NTWELEWR. OOUKON.
U  BED TY
TINASTOT ONEFINELEYMIIFAV AUR QE
FI,TEDS TUT PASN 00 POULELSLYMHE
.SBEIT S IBERA W G K SSIONTAGFRO
Y. UIECHE  ASG. H A'  T DHEH.ERO
DUN
TREMOSO.SI TETASTT TINEOEE TENM
PP
EAKOSHIHEUTHA0 TPL N ELDE O
SEBIUTTHDERTEERROEDGROT FAP
NDMAASRU HP,Y LE  TBRTH
LYINEADL MRES
SYPS MHAE
SECOIVRTADNCLIH OSES TOPAPNG
EW COR IN BMPE  T  ON